an info sticker for tire pressure and
maximum loads this one is for a Skoda
but how many of us check our own car
regularly drive it and the German auto
club a DAC joined up to show what can
happen when you don't stick to the
guidelines the empty skoda octavia
easily handled the swerve tests the
vehicle remained under control at all
stages and the average braking distance
at 100 kilometers an hour was 43.3
meters
then we filled it with all the baggage
that a family of four would take on
holiday and we fitted a rule Fox
repeating the swerve test fully loaded
the octavia was clearly harder to handle
thanks to the SCOTUS ESP our experienced
driver could keep the car under control
then we decide to go one step further a
heavy suitcase goes on the roof full
water containers in the back taking the
Octavia well above the legal load limits
the result is eye-opening the vehicle
can barely maneuver safely at all we see
skidding and over steering the evidence
all points to one conclusion valve seat
us late deafened Giuliani of the ad AC
says the empty vehicle handled extremely
well but the loaded vehicle was much
more difficult to control the ESP had a
stabilizing effect but the driver had to
react forcefully the overloaded vehicle
was almost uncontrollable the thias p
was overtaxed and couldn't keep the car
on course but it's not just the total
weight that has to be taken into account
there is also the permissible axle and
roof loads all interior luggage should
be secured with straps
these crash-test images show what can
happen when it isn't properly tied down
classic holiday bring along slike cool
boxes and bocce balls can turn into
lethal projectiles so remember to pack
sensibly and not cram every available
space it could save your life
you